and then start okay uh welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone before we introduce our invited speaker
let's go over some rules and Logistics first of
all please mute yourself during the talk but if
you have a question you cannot mute and ask
questions during during the talk or you can
use chat room to post your questions so that we
can address them in between HSN at the end second
to today's ddps stamina is open to external
audiences therefore no classified discussion
is allowed and finally The Talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our YouTube channel
that's it let me briefly introduce our speaker
today it's an honor to host Dr Eleni tetsi who is
an associate professor and chair of structural
mechanics and monitoring at the department of
civil and environmental and geomatic Engineering
at eth Zurich our research interests include
the field of structural Health monitoring and
structural Dynamics and intelligent data-driven
assessment of Engineering Systems today Eleni
will present an exciting topic which is training
and model Discovery for engineered systems I'm
sure we will hear an exciting exciting talk today
but before I pass the button to Eleni let me ask a
couple of questions just to get to know you better
learning and make this seminar someone in inform
in promo all right are you ready yes go ahead all
right the first question is obviously you are
passionate about structural Health monitoring
and structural Dynamics in general is there any
moment in your life when you realize that wow this
is it this is the field I would like to commit my
career onto this field do you have that moment hmm
I you know a moment of realization that's a good
question I should explain you know monitoring for
me was something new uh to discover when I came to
the us at the Columbia University to work at the
engineering uh civil engineering and Engineering
mechanics department on this theme until then I
followed the more traditional civil engineering
studies that were not so much into the concept of
data system identification exploitation of such
Technologies let's say at that point in time
and so it was already something new and exciting
which sparked my interest from the beginning of
my doctoral studies but I think the realization
came near the third year of my studies when I
actually got to go on the Manhattan Bridge which
is an iconic structure in in New York and you know
the Chloe sensors sensing instruments ourselves
together with the group of my advisor at the
time Professor Andrew Smith and actually you
know gather the data that was to be used for
something practical for something that I could see
a tangible outcome and at that point I realized
okay this is something I would like to do and it's
not just about maybe Theory which is on its own
exciting but it's possibly something that could
help me effectively make a difference or you know
at least uh uh seed applied in a way that makes
sense and I think that's what made uh made me more
excited and that's when I decided to get into this
in a bit more serious or academic I guess manner
very nice so you do have that moment I feel like
this was it for me that's true but you can never
things form the government the
accumulation of several smaller
experiences that somehow adapt to something
but maybe the realization yeah could depend
down to a moment I suppose all right the
second question which is the last question
you are now serving as vice president of the
European Academy of wind energy that's a such a
big job sounds like how did it how did it happen
would you mind sharing a brief story about it
um yes so maybe this is closely related
to what the experience I described before
so for me applications in Wind engineering came
rather uh it's not that recently but I think it
was not until 2015 actually or 14 rather on
the occasion of a grant that I was writing
that is equivalent to a career Grant in the US
it's a New York City starting Grant in Europe
um where you know the idea was to suggest a topic
that was new and bold something that hasn't really
been tried before and at the time the structural
monitoring of wind energy structures was not
really something that was heavily pursued not
much work existed from the point of view of
uh methods that exploited structural monitoring
data structural mechanics models in tandem with
data and so so the approval of that ground I
began to become I sort of entered this realm
of wind energy structures which was again new
to me at the time but I also came slowly to
know the different colleagues to work more closely
with colleagues in Europe and eventually entered
this European Academy of wind energy where
many of the colleagues that work in the wind
energy domain participate to represent their
institutions and that's how I became a member
of that society and now I'm the vice president
of the society at the moment representing the
field of structural monitoring and representing
it and actually a field that is in itself very
very broad so we have colleagues from the domains
of control Power grids electrical engineering uh
civil more traditional or structural analysis
groups and of course fluid simulation so it's
really a very diverse field that has to somehow
work in tandem for a common goal which is
actually the resilience and the performance
design of these systems and structures so I
guess something new and exciting for me not
so new maybe anymore but certainly remains
exciting through the interdisciplinarity of the
topic so I'm glad to be part of this Mr Society
awesome awesome well you know the excitement
follows some responsibility I guess so um yes
this is true especially when these societies
are as diverse but it's also a pleasure to
to work with colleagues from all these
different Origins and uh I guess skills
and interests awesome awesome all right I
will not bother you with any more questions
um so the floor is yours you can share your
slide and then um let me try but I think you
mentioned that we could also take questions
during so that's also welcomed for me awesome
um and I'm going to try and give a small overview
here of the work that we do in my group the chair
of structural mechanics and monitoring and tth
Zurich on this theme the theme of training and
model Discovery for engineered systems and you
already see a wind turbine there because it has
become or it has grown to become a substantial
portion of what we deal with but the truth is
that our applications funnier and long uh a rather
broad domain of applications with a golden thread
being this concept of structural Health monitoring
with your first question allowed me to elaborate
on instructional Health monitoring from my point
of view can only be conceptualized as a chain a
chain which initiates with the Gathering and
accumulation of data from different types of
sensing sources offering heterogeneous information
of diverse types in my group we're particularly
interested of in exploding vibration based
signals because often they are very rich in
content and information and that's also why
we um in the term of social mechanics and
monitoring one of the domains of our expertise
is also structural Dynamics now what we try to
do on the basis of this accumulated data is to
exploit the information and translate it into
something that is interpretable something that
can be used by Engineers for their management
for the management of their assets typically in
two configurations the diagnostic configuration
where we try to assess the condition of the system
as is and the prognostic configuration where we're
interested to learn more or predict rather the
future performance or remaining useful life of
a system extracting quantifiable indicators that
can guide us to their operational maintenance and
overall management now of course the translation
of data into something that is Meaningful
information is non-trivial and this is where the
strengths of what we develop comes in or at least
the particular expertise of my group which which
lies in the exploitation of models that draw from
principles of physics physics represented in
the sense of mechanics or Dynamics and where
through these models we can actually maximize the
information that can be drawn from the raw data
and after creating this kind of a Synergy and
trying creating these quantifiable metrics of
system performance we try to then extend these
to the system level so I spoke earlier when
turbines but we're also interested in trying to
understand performance at the level of the farm
or if the fleet of farms that are operating
or on which we draw data from or if we're
talking about more conventional civil engineering
infrastructure we would be talking not only about
individual Bridges or Road components but rather
of the transport Network as a whole as an entity
that can be managed on the basis of flow of data
so these are the elements of the chain that make
up shm but also the chain that is relevant for
us in terms of the fields that we're active in
so uh as I mentioned before we gather data from
various systems we have a collaboration with the
railway authorities here in Zurich where we
use sensors mounted on trains or vehicles to
understand the performance not only on the
vehicle Fleet side but also the traversed
infrastructure side we deal with more traditional
civil engineering applications like the monitoring
of buildings under for example seismic excitations
or the monitoring of bridges under the different
types of loads that they are exposed to including
aging and slow evolving deterioration forcings
and of course talking about condition monitoring
we also have applications in the more traditional
area of industrial assets and of course wind
energy structures in fact it may be interesting
to know that we even own a turbine so this is
a turbine that is not too not too far from our
campus from which we use as a living lab it's
sort of a toy in the sense that we try to use
an experiment with for testing and verifying our
methodologies uh and so I will focus in this talk
um as the title somehow hints on the aspect
of modeling or the inference of models and
how this can be used in a way that makes sense
or maximizes our understanding of a system which
is what we would like to do at the end of the day
but before I do that I always think it interesting
to also point out what we can do on the basis of
pure uh exploitation of data without necessarily
trying to include some knowledge of the physics
that underpins our problem and to do this I will
show you again an interesting application again
here at the farm actually level from wind energy
monitoring so in this case we're trying to see we
can produce a data-driven model that can capture
the effect of wakes which is actually the effect
that this front turbines will have as you see it
here this shadow that is created on the basis
of how the wind is oriented within a site which
has implications for the downstream turbines not
only in terms of the power that they produce but
also in terms of the loads that they experience
and therefore the fatiguing of these turbines
and eventually given their condition through the
accumulation of such wake effects now if you would
like to model this with physics the program could
become quite complicated and there are models that
try to approximate the problem but of course
there's no guarantee that they reflect exactly
what is the condition on site so to tackle this
issue we actually use the data that we monitor
um that we draw from monitoring of this turbine
so data at the level of the Hub that give us
information about the mean wind speed and our
orientation as well as the power production
but also moment data that have has to do with the
loads that are experienced by these turbines and
we try to develop a data-driven model in this
case which admits as an input the mean wind
field conditions as you would gather them from a
meteorological Mast and translate them into what
is the prediction of the wind that will affect
the individual turbines and by extension what are
actually engineering critical quantities like
the wind deficit that would be experienced by
this turbines but depending on the orientation
of this mean wind and the way in which we did
that here has no physics actually it draws from
the learning on the rich collected data over a
large period of time and we use conditional
variational autoencoders to create this
generated model in the Continental conditioning
was of course done on these mean wind conditions
which is essentially what defines the output
and the prediction of these models so this is
nice because this is something that reflects the
reality it's still a model it's still a generated
model but of course and we didn't have to use any
complex physics-based um information that could
probably also take a long time to compute uh at
the same time it gives us information on critical
quantities in this case we can also compute
damage equivalent loads which from the engineering
perspective is important for judging us to the
operation of these systems but the issue is we
cannot always get away with neglecting physics
and it's great when we have these loads of data
at least of that form as I showed you for turbines
the scada information that ensure this knowledge
on wind conditions but there exist quantities
that are not so easy to infer or to understand
just by straightforwardly looking at the raw
data uh one such aspect is the Dynamics that
may be underlying the system and this is something
we're interested to know because it could actually
um Define its performance and so as I mentioned
before we typically are in the business of
collecting Dynamics data or vibration based data
usually by mounting acceleration or saying gauge
type of sensors here you see an installation okay
it's a graphic but it's a typical installation we
also have on real systems an array of sensors
for example on a tower of a wind turbine from
which vibration response would be collected and
here what we would like to do as an interim stage
where we try to bias a bit on the knowledge
of you know the Dynamics that is governed in
the system we try to represent this by using
appropriate time series based representations
again they are data driven but within them they
carry the structure of the expected Dynamics I
will describe a bit on this in what follows
so in this case we're trying to describe our
Dynamics with parameterized models and at the
same time we know that the performance of a
system over the long period of time is dependent
on the influencing environmental and operational
variables again the mean wind field direction or
speed which could change over time it could be
the temperature and humidity conditions the wave
loadings that are seasonal and so in order to have
a holistic model that can capture the condition or
rather the response of the system over an extended
period of time we try to build these dependence
models which are really by component models one
part to take on the response of the system that
is measured in the short time and a dependence
model to take on the influence of external agents
or these environmental and operational variables
onto the response of the system there are many
ways to achieve this dependence and I'm listing
here only some of these at least the ones that
we have worked with but at the end of the day
what is important is that we have we can manage to
construct hierarchical models which are predicted
models of the quantities that we measure and which
we can then use as a means to create a conditional
assessors of the system that can then signal us
to possible damage now I want to say here why
I mentioned before that this data-driven models
that are time history essentially uh type of Time
series types of type of models actually uh encode
within them some of the Dynamics of the system and
this is because if we have a non-linear system we
know that we could approximate it by using compact
parametric representations of that auto regressive
type which are particularly suited for non-linear
models this would be the nonlinear Auto regressive
class of models which you see listed here and
similarly for non-stationary systems we could
have corresponding parametric representations like
a discrete wavelet transform or for time varying
systems which is really what our wind turbines are
we could use a Time varying Auto regressive class
of models to encode the Dynamics that we expect in
the model that we try to use to approximate the
system and this is quite convenient because when
you want to have a holistic representation and
it dependence on influencing agents A parametric
model gives a natural means to do so because
these coefficients or parameters of the model
can be conditioned on these influencing agents and
this is one way to do this actually the expression
that you see here is through a polynomial chaos
expansion it's basically an input output surrogate
stochastic surrogate which gives the dependence of
these coefficients as the and environment changes
here is a practical example of this unreal
measurements so this is an acceleration time
history from a tower of wind turbine one of the
turbines that we monitor the specific one is in
Germany actually and here you see the spectrogram
that would correspond to this plot in the Contour
now in the spectrogram through the intensity of
the colors it is clear that the frequencies of
this dynamic system are not constant so we're not
talking here about the stationary system a system
which under traditional system identification
tools would be easy to understand through what
we call operational model analysis methods but
rather a system that is time wiring and where
a time-wiring model such as a Time Value motor
regressive model as I mentioned before could be
used to track the evolution of the Dynamics and
this is what we did here this is what you see
superimposed through these blue curves that are
really able to track the evolution of the Dynamics
in the short short time 10 minute window now the
problem when we collect our data is that of course
if I look at another 10 minute window with another
mean speed of the wind or Min orientation of the
wind this portrait would likely change it would
change because it's conditioned to this external
agents and this is actually something that we
can take on through the dependent structure so
a gaussian process or a polynomial case exposure
level and neural network model could be used
to express this dependence and to reflect the
evolution of the Dynamics of a longer period of
time for example here you see the modulation over
a period of a month the conditioning is done on
data that is collected and that's the nice thing
about wind energy wind turbine structures that we
traditionally collect this supervisory control and
data acquisition scada information which give us a
10 minute average data on wind direction speed
power temperature and many more parameters and
this is what we condition on and if we can do
that then we can train for a sufficient period
of time our hierarchical model and then use it as
a predictor and understand the deviation between
what we predict and what it is we measured of
course there will be outliers which have to
admit the robust outlier analysis and statistical
analysis so that we can then classify the alarms
that we receive or rather the indication the
indicators that we calculate as in the green
region so operating operating as expected in
normal conditions in the red region so in known
environmental conditions we receive alarms so
this means we have to act or we have to signal for
repair or intervention on our system or we receive
alarms which are actually outside of the regular
um thresholds of our environmental essay
conditions and this is what we would
issue as an orange alarm which means that
there's something off but it could be off
because we are in a new environment and this is
something we have to treat with further analysis
so in structural Health monitoring and
because we're in close collaboration often
with operators and Engineers we like to present
these red red number green type of alarms to the
um to let's say the stakeholders and this is
something that they're more comfortable with
that they understand more so than just a plot
without Liars let's say and one step further we
can even help them to localize damage up to
a degree for example this is something that
we have done on a bridge structure which you
see here it's a bridge in Switzerland which
we controllably damaged with different scenarios
that we inflicted ourselves so that we can know
where damage is located at and we showed that
by using a network of sensors now not looking at
individual sensors but at the changes with respect
to how the sensors are placed it is possible to a
degree to also localize perhaps the damage and of
course this will depend depends on the density of
the central Network and a few more configurational
aspects but what it tells us is that we are quite
successful up to this point in diagnosing damage
understanding if it exists and maybe where it is
but if we just want to stick to the data we cannot
do more than that so we cannot prognose what
happens next or how longer our system can go for
without actually experiencing a critical failure
so the moment we want to go a step further we
maintain the data on its own is actually not
enough and this is the point where in our analysis
it is important to bring in an engineering model
a model that goes beyond the purely data driven
representation and the diagnostic capabilities
that brings in the physics that can help us in
a sense extrapolate or understand how the system
can perform all the while being updated by the
data reflecting our system as is so this kind of
a concept of merging physics and Engineering
intuition and models with data is the hybrid
approach to modeling is what allows us to go
to produce this so-called twins twins that
are actually interactive that somehow close
the loop of communication between the actual
physical system and the virtual um mirror
or the virtual instance that we are creating
since there is always this communication
flow that is ensured by the by the data
uh precisely because this interaction is important
in our group we pay particular attention to models
that can compute fast compute ideally in real time
so that we can ensure that we have a connection
between the two systems the digital and the
physical system always and without interruption
but to do this we have to ensure that the
computational tool of our models has to be
low a task which is actually non-trivial and on
which I would like to actually focus on so let me
actually go directly here how we can fuse data and
physics-based models for learning monitoring and
training and physically do so in real time now the
reason why this is uh not an easy task is not only
because of the complexity of the models which is
often what causes them to uh be slow in terms of
computation but it's also because uh the effects
that we have to account for are rather complex I
already refer to the aspect of loads that reflect
varying environmental and operational conditions
this could also refer to loads that lead our
systems to experience non-linear Behavior
behavior that is beyond the easy to compute
let's say linear elastic range in fact most
of our loadings are distributed loading so it's
not easy to model these with just simplified
Point sources and further to this they're also
in most of the cases actually unknown or even
unmeasured and so we have to deal with all of
these intricacies and try to deliver a predicted
model that can cope with this uncertainty and do
so in real time and the motivation being that we
would like to use this as explained before for
for training applications for the goal of virtual
sensing virtual sensing is the situation where
we wish to extract information from a system
predicted information beyond the usually few
and sparse locations where we sense and when we
try to construct a proper digital twin this is
very very important because we should not just
be predicting where we measure but rather in the
full field of this object that we try to monitor
um and of course the downstream tasks are numerous
including control and diagnostic aspects that have
to do with maintenance so I will pick one of these
um tasks to exemplify the framework that we have
set up and for me the most interesting as I sort
of hinted is the aspect of virtual sensing predict
the response of the system feasibly in real time
in locations that are not measured or as I come
to refer to it basically achieving everything
everywhere all at once and here's what I mean
by this uh this is our typical monitoring problem
where we have a structural system uh on which some
sensors usually few and spars are located on this
gives us some sort of measurement information our
system is operating under inputs that we usually
we cannot measure that's the case for a bridge
even for a wind turbine we claim to know the wind
speed and direction but we don't really know the
proper distributed uh um force of the wind or the
wave as it is acting on our offshore structure
we have as Engineers some sort of a priority
model that was used to put the system in place
but usually it's not an accurate model or at least
it's not a model that has been updated necessarily
to reflect the system at its current point in
time and therefore it could feature unknown
parameters additional to model form uncertainty
and the objective is to extract the response of
the system and this so-called unknown States
is the response of the system in unmeasured
locations which actually can be numerous so we
would like to do all of this learn the system
predict its response so everything we would
like to do it everywhere in the full field of
the system and we would like to do it in real
time which is basically all at once given all
of the challenges that I mentioned earlier uh
so here is how we try to approach the problem
for doing so first of all we have to reduce the
computation of our engineering models which we
wish to bring in the loop and in our group we are
structural mechanics group so we have had exposure
to and we helped in development of numerous
methods on the more traditional fronts for
um accelerating computation from the point of view
of fractured plasticity geometric non-linearity
or multi-structural complex assemblies but not
uh that the majority of these methods just does
not make the cut when we try to use them as is
we need to boost this kind of a computation and
one way to do this and which is quite popular in
recent years is to do it through exploitation of
the power of learning through machine or deep
learning formulations uh all the while though
respecting the fact that we have to learn
from physics and Engineering information
so here's one approach to doing this this is work
by Thomas Simpson one of the PHD candidates who
recently graduated from our group who tried to
reduce full order complex finite element models
so for civil engineering this is one of the
favorite types of models usually with a large
number of degrees of freedom which compute in
terms of Dynamics most often quite slow and so
what we did was to train on several instances of
such models uh or at least on several four things
that are applied onto such models to extract
the so-called latent representation of this
multi-degree of Freedom system essentially A
reduced order of space where the Dynamics of
the problem lives in and can be characterized but
with the condensed representation and then we try
to apply the forcing the actual forcing of the
system onto this reduced representation and we
used a numerical integrator or the equivalent
of this for neural networks which is a in our
case an lstm RNN type of model that takes
our prediction from point time TK to the
next point in time so now we have computation on
reduced coordinates and we have a possibility to
simulate the system in this reduced space over
time at the same time through the nice property
of Auto encoders we can go back to our original
representation the original finite element model
through the decoding step and extract the response
over desired system in the full field in terms of
strains or accelerations in general in terms
of the quantities that we're actually going
to measure eventually from this system uh simply
through this decoding procedure so this gives a
significant acceleration it allowed us to simulate
the systems that are non-linear so this one
it's actually a non-linear Benchmark that was
defined by our colleagues in Los Alamos in the
U.S a non-linear frame with a bumper where the
response of the system is challenging to simulate
with traditional system identification tools that
prefer linear systems so here we simulated the
system using this autoencoder logic showing that
the reduced space that we extract from the system
is actually a type of non-linear normal mode so
they're basically modes that are independent the
majority of the spectral content of these modes
reflects a specific actually frequency there's
still non-linear representations but it's actually
what empowers us to then simulate the system using
this reduced representation even at the non-linear
case from a practical Viewpoint we implemented
this Logic on the non-linear response of Monopoly
wind turbines where non-linearity comes from the
behavior of the soil where you see typical py
curves on the basis of which the engineers wind
Engineers will simulate these models and that's
indeed what our colleagues in Siemens camessa
did they did the actual simulations on which we
trained this uh autoencoder type of reduced order
model which then replaced their simulation with
high accuracy only it did so in fragments of a
second meaning it gave us a computational modeling
which can compute in real time and it can be later
combined with data which is really what we seek
to do a bit of an issue in this reduction approach
is that for most of these configurations uh we
haven't so far discussed the issue of simulating
systems of different parameters so even in this
monopole structure it's actually a fixed structure
and system but which we simulate under different
types of loads and we try to accelerate the
simulation for this particular instance but if you
want to have a general model that can compute over
different parameters and different configurations
so different shapes of the Tower or lengths of the
blades and whatnot we have to compute we have
to construct a so-called parametric surrogate
and to do this one of the approaches that
we follow is the so-called projection based
parametric reduction and I'm going to exemplify
this on a benchmark that we tried to put out for
the community um it should be that this QR code
hopefully still works this is this would take
you to the page where this Benchmark is defined
of course we're in the civil engineering so our
Benchmark is a common civil structure it's a
frame which however features non-linear joints
so each one of these links are described by a
hysterectic model it's actually a book one type
of model which means that the response of the
system to earthquake loading which is a typical
excitation for the analysis of these structures is
non-linear and what we would like to do here is to
produce a parametric model so I reduced all their
models that can run for different configurations
of this system meaning for different properties
of the hysteretic model of this non-linear joints
but also for different characteristics of the
input forcing the earthquake which can come at
different amplitudes and with different spectral
contents so to try and do this the first thing
we have to do is to actually parameterize
our input because we need also the input
to be something that can form a part of our
defining the defining parameters of our model
and it turns out that for earthquake sequences
it is possible to actually parameterize this
and this was shown in the work of Verizon in the
caregion and we followed that work and essentially
took real instances of earthquakes from the
pure strong motion database where more than 2
000 actual earthquake time sequences have been
recorded and we broke them down into parameters
that essentially have to do with the spectral
and temporal characteristics of the earthquake
how the amplitude evolves over time and what is
the spectral content of the earthquake sequence
and by breaking them down into these parameters we
can actually now take a specific earthquake time
series represented with these parameters that
now form part of the definition of our problem
but perhaps the more difficult aspect here is to
see how to reduce the non-linear system itself so
okay we parameterize the input uh the load but we
also wish to execute our simulation for different
characteristics of our frame maybe different
elastic characteristic but also hysteretic
uh properties and so to do this in affordable
computational time we follow a projection based
approach where the original non-linear Dynamic
equation of the problem which is an ordinary
differential equation is brought down into a
much smaller Dimension a dimension r that is
Affordable to compute and the key to doing this is
to construct or to multiply our original equation
with this reduction basis which is basically like
a Larkin projection basis all this is in simple
words is basically a matrix that we assemble
by having several simulations we call them
snapshots of the original full order model and by
executing a singular value decomposition on those
several time series it is possible to extract this
gallerykin projection basis essentially a matrix
again of main modes that govern the response
of the non-linear system and by pre and post
multiplying with this Matrix we end up in this
reduced still non-linear equation which is also a
parametric it has a parametric dependence now what
this means is because parametric the parametric
dependence exists is that we have to compute these
bases in different regions of our parametric space
and there's different ways that people approach
this problem different groups or different works
in the literature approach the problem one of
the more popular ones is to create clusters in
the parametric space and just compute these basis
for snapshots within that cluster what is not so
nice about this approach or at least bothered me
was the fact that it's not a smooth dependence
relationship so in an effort to develop something
like this we have proposed this coefficient Matrix
interpolation scheme where the reduced order
matrices are produced through a double projection
first a projection to have the local basis
a second projection to extract a coefficient
dependence of these local bases on our on a global
uh basis coefficient on a global basis Matrix
and the connection between the two is actually
enforced through an autoencoder the tool that
we used previously for reduction is now used for
expressing this dependence relationship giving
us basis matrices on the on by inputting specific
sets of our parametric space what does this mean
so given the problem of our frame for different
parameters of the load of the earthquake but also
different parameters of the configuration of the
frame we can produce through this conditioning
this conditional variation a lot of encoder the
coefficient Vector which when multiplied with a
global basis Matrix that I can generate from my
snapshots my original simulations will give me
targeted local basis that will Define the new
reduced equation of the problem that I need to
solve and so this is the way in which we tackle
this problem which gave us really as at least for
this kind of an application an edge we can compute
with higher accuracy but also quite interestingly
uh uh some co-accelerated computational time
but more importantly for us we can also generate
confidence intervals for our prediction and what
empowers us to produce this confidence intervals
is the fact that we use a variational autoencoder
which is on its own a sampling approach so our
latent space is no longer a deterministic
space but it's actually a distribution which
allows us to generate the samples that can then
create this prediction which is stochastic in
nature and something that's important to give
also a confidence in the prediction that we
furnish which is at the end of the day always an
approximation so this is our attempt to reduction
and now I would like to take a portion of the talk
to discuss the connection with data in real time
so we know we can reduce our modems but how do
we bring the data into play and one way to do
this at least one way that we have long worked
for in our group is to do it through Bayesian
Bayesian filtering formulations how does this work
well we still have this equation of the Dynamics
which requires a model of the system possibly
a reduced order model as I mentioned before
but We additionally have an observation equation
these are the few and sparse measurements that we
extract from the system it's not only degrees of
freedom but the ones that we have the luxury to
instrument and draw information from now the
combination of the model in the data can be
achieved by using evasion logic which is really
a two-step logic first we predict the response of
our system at the next point in time by using the
equation of our system which was essentially this
state space formulation even if it's a non-linear
State space formulation and the second step is
to update our estimation on the basis of the
discrepancy between what we predict and what we
measure at those sparse locations and these are
represented here through the likelihood and the
prior which which are basically combined through
the Bayesian logic to give us a posterior estimate
of the response of the system at the next point
in time a posterior that is conditioned on the
data that we collect but also in the physics which
is imprinted on the models on the equations that
Define the likelihood and the prior so here's how
this works for non-linear systems it is not easy
to use linear formulations like the Kalman filter
for those who are familiar with these specific
formulations instead we have to relax a bit or
simulation and we use approximations that are
based on samples so assume you have a dynamic
system at a given point in time it's state its
response is approximated with sampling which tries
to represent the probability that our system is at
a given displacement and velocity configuration
at that point in time we have an equation a
state equation usually which can be a non-linear
reduced order model that can tell us what is the
response of our system at the next point in time
this would be what we call our prior and then we
also have measurements which can give us a sense
of how far what we predict is from the reality and
this is uh then weighed in through Bayes theorem
to give us the posterior estimate of the response
of the system and all of this is achieved through
the use of reduced ordered models and because of
this it can be done in real time for different
types of tasks of Interest including control
and Diagnostics now in our group we have worked
as for a long time actually essentially since
the end of my PhD on schemes that are using this
patient logic Force State estimation meaning the
response of the system joint State and parameter
estimation so we can also actually infer the
parameter the parameters of the system when these
are assumed as unknowns or input State estimation
because I mentioned that the inputs and the loads
are hardly ever precisely measured so there is a
way to use this framework to also assess the
loads or to assess everything everywhere all
at once which is everything the input the state
and the parameter of the system of course given
specific properties are respected because this
can be a very ill problem otherwise uh so let
me show you an example of how this can work and to
do this I will use a simulated case study which is
from one of our projects that was on Aerospace
structures and there the idea was to use a few
sensors that could be mounted for example on the
fuselage and understand what is the response of
the system first of all in non-measured locations
so so that we get a fully filled image of how the
structure response but to also possibly detect
the presence of faults and defects in these thin
cell structures usually come in the form of
cracking which could be in multiple locations
and so to do this we will use physics and the
physics we use in our group is an extended finite
element approach which is particularly suited for
fracture but it's not real time so we will have to
also use the reduced order modeling approach that
I mentioned before but where a challenge exists
in our Bringing Down the equations of the problem
from this full Dimension to A reduced Dimension
because now in order to extract these modes
of the system it is important for us to have
a configuration of the system That Remains the
Same under different parametric configurations
and here's the problem when a parameter of
the system is a crack which can have different
locations if I am to use different meshes or
even the x-frame approach which is particularly
adapting keeping the same mesh but still adding
the degrees of freedom suddenly if the location
of the crack changes I would not be able to have
the same type of reference for my system I would
not be able to produce modes that much or make
sense because of these crack parameters I would
have a non-smooth problem which however we try to
tackle by bringing back our knowledge from physics
and mechanics so we used a sort of trick we used
mesh morphing where we take the original curved
configuration first we map it into a flat mesh and
we assume that we have a reference crack somewhere
located conveniently within the main body of
the object which we then distort we basically
distort the mesh using modifying the universe
distance waiting which allows us to bring the
original crack into a new location so we can then
represent a new crack within our space but using
the exact same nodes and the numbering remaining
the same which means that I can then also use this
logic of reduction by referring to the same node
number so now I am able to use the reduced order
model that I explained before to approximate the
dynamic response of a cracked curved surface and
I can do it in real time which is actually faster
than this video exactly for us and this means that
I can also feed the measurements that I have in
the bedroom logic that I showed before together
with this reduced model and indeed this is what
we do there is actually even a further step of
complexity here because the input in this kind
of system is certainly not measured so I have
to operate with a filter that can tackle unknown
inputs and this type of Fleet there are many such
filters here we use an augmented Kalman filter
to do this and in fact we use a bank parallel
installations of this filter so that we can
actually at the same time infer not only the
response of the system but also the parameters
of the system which include the location of
the crack which is the defect we're trying to
identify this shows you the convergence of our
algorithm as we start from random locations and
assumptions of faults and their positions at time
zero and slowly as the estimation progresses
we have convergence to the drum location of
these fonts and quite importantly for us we also
have the possibility to estimate the response of
the system in non-measured locations these green
locations are not sensed so we can actually quite
fairly it's a simulated problem so here maybe
it's a bit easier but we can show that we can
reproduce the response of the system and in fact
we can do it at a fraction of the time that is
required even by improved solvers and accelerated
models so in 22 seconds would be the best case
scenario for a FM based approach Point 12
seconds is what the surrogate here can achieve
um there is a further complexity here that I'm
not going to go into the into details of so I'd
rather just keep this for later in case there
is interest for this it's how we would tackle uh
further challenges relating to input so let me see
if I can skip this uh because it seems a bit stuck
ah there we go so what I would like to discuss
here finally is the aspect of model discrepancy
because what I showed before actually is very
nice and I will show that it works well on
simulated data but what happens in real cases
is that additionally to uncertain inputs and
uncertain parameters of our models we also have
model mismatch what we call model form uncertainty
in other words we can never promise that our
physics is good enough to capture the full
phenomenon of what we observe and to tackle this
we have been working with our group in Singapore
as well with but primarily with this group on
the development of physics enhanced as we call
it or physics infused learning and we have been
playing with schemes that are so-called physics
guided schemes where the physics comes through
explicit incorporation of equations into the
problem physics encoded schemes where we try to
force the neural network architecture to respect
the physics of the problem for example we use a
neurologies to reflect systems that form ordinary
differential equations or physics informed schemes
where the infusion of the physics is a bit more
loose but it tries to bring in Concepts like
hamiltonian principles symplectic integration
that would go well with those principles or
physics informed neural networks where again
in the likelihood function we try to demand the
satisfaction of specific governing equations
so we try to actually organize the different tools
that exist in the Spectrum which reflects the use
of physics versus the use of data so the Bayesian
filtering scheme that I mentioned earlier tends
to use a lot of physics but requires less data
because it assumes a good knowledge of the physics
that's underlying the problem but as we go into
more physics agnostic representations we'll try
to We tend to rely more heavily on the data or we
can try to merge the two into something that is a
compromise and that's what I would like to show
here as a final application an application which
we use for drive-by monitoring this is basically
the assessment of traversed infrastructure the
roads or Railways by trains or cars where
the sensors are mounted on the vehicles the
collected information is vibration and we try to
assess the condition of the infrastructure itself
we do this by using these models that are in the
in between or gray zone of that Spectrum where we
have some knowledge of the physics but it's not
perfect and we we add a learning model that is
there to take on the portion of the physics that
we simply do not know or is at least hidden to us
by superimposing these terms and learning a
combination of the two we're able to make up
for this model for mismatch but we're also able to
bias what would have been a purely Black Box model
by the partial physics that we know it's in which
operates beneficially for our system here's a
simple example this is the case uh actually let me
not go into the details of this but let me rather
show you this application the simple example for
the case of drive by monitoring where we're trying
to understand the roughness of the road surface
and where we fuse a model of the vehicle uh at
least a partial model of the vehicle that tries to
approximate it plus a portion that is a learning
term a deep learning term that tries to make up
for the unknown or the model form discrepancy
and there is actually a logic a waiting factor
that is the optional optimal combination of the
two this is actually not something that the user
Tunes this is just forced here to show the point
it's something that is learned by the framework
and that allows us to get the best of both worlds
we have actually also experimentally validated
this logic because I'm close to the end I will
not show you the experimental validation I will
just like to go to this sort of leave you with
what we what I think is next after this kind of
fusion uh which is the last portion of the chain
that I showed in the beginning and that was
about handling uh systems of systems and here
is such an example at the ecosystem level here
we try to harness information for wind farms
but we're trying to do it in a way that can allow
for transfer of knowledge so we have models first
of all of uh Wind Farm layouts where we try to
uh which we try to approximate using a graph
representation we consider a graph representation
as possibly the most comfortable representation
for representing systems that have a geometric
distribution this is true not only for structures
that admit a mesh but also for wind turbines
which are individual entities distributed within
a farm and by training such graph neural
network based models we're able to train
on specific configurations on which we have data
or simulated but even real data and then we try
to simulate systems of new and unseen geometric
configurations purely as forward simulations to
produce quantities of interest and we show that
it is possible to produce and with such quantities
of the interest like the power produce the
turbulence intensity that is experienced
the damage equivalent load on the basis of few
inputs like the mean wind field conditions in
the farm and training on different separate farm
geometries and the power of such a transfer lies
in the exploitation of the principle of graphs and
this is what we would like to use therefore for
the so-called upper population based shm approach
where we don't just care about the individual
structure but the Assembly of these structures
uh I would like to close with this this sort of
a holistic view of the framework we would like
to put in place which takes us from exploitation
of data the fusion of this data with physics to
extract Hybrid models that are more informative
offer this information to the experts and
stakeholders for decision support and then augment
this kind of management to the level of fields
and ecosystems of different types of structures
so I think this is a good slide to
close since I'm very close to the end
and ask for any questions that you have on
this sort of chain that I tried to explain
thank you thank you so much I mean it
sounds like a you have a lot more to
present uh actually it feels like we have
to invite you one more time no I think I
try so I think I took a bit more time than
I planned and I'm sorry for this gives an
overview of what we have yeah yeah I
mean we saw the cine picture of a lot
of stuff but I you know every single
snippet was pretty uh interesting and
exciting uh I can see I I can see why
you are so excited about your project
um just by listening to your talk that was
awesome all right let's have a q a session
if you have any questions please um you know
unmute yourself and ask questions [Music] um
yeah go ahead hi Lenny good
to see you in this context
yeah it's nice to see you hi um I mean it
was very very detailed presentation I have
it a high level question for you because all of
us through the world the the words digital twin
around and uh if you if you were to Define it
yourself what would you say it is uh well you
know in the context of you know the digital twin
has come to grow into something that is exploited
by many different disciplines I love in this
sense I think it can also have many different
meanings I mean it's different for beam right
the building information modeling made where
it's more of an instantiation of a system uh for
monitoring however it is extremely important for
this twin to be interactive and continuously
updated which means that we sort of have to
have this sort of disclosed Loop which allows
us to always understand the condition of the
system and give it makes it possible for us to
intervene and it's very similar in control and
I know that you know you know probably you share
the opinion from your applications if you wish to
be able to interact with the system it cannot
be without having this constant supervision so
it a twin for me something that has a closed-loop
communication with the actual physical system and
that's not always the case and maybe it's fine
but in our context this is what it should be
yeah that that makes sense I think
yeah I think context defines it and
and everybody's stealing it
for the purpose of marketing
and I really like your last slide and I
will steal it um and then sure everything
is connected I think that's that's the essence
of it thank you beautiful talk thank you well
well related to the beautiful slide I'm Eleni
would you mind sharing your slide yeah yeah let
me do that again I did it because I couldn't
see the audience otherwise but maybe I can
uh um I have to do full screen is it visible
now wrong yeah awesome well I I I see that
and that's just the last slide but I see
um many other slides were pretty beautiful
all right sounds good uh there's
a question in chat room by Peter
well um instead of me asking maybe
Peter do you want to unmute yourself
and ask ask that question yourself
or do you want me to video for you
oh okay I have to stop the screen share
I think again yeah I I can read it for
you Peter has a mic issue um is the cultural
relationship between inputs and outputs of the
interest always clear or do you sometimes have
to perform additional data analysis to establish
the causality prior to the development of a
physical model yeah this is a very good question
because as I mentioned at one point of the
presentation it's very easy to end up with an
early post problem when you when we claim that
you know there are many things that we do not
know including uh the actual loading source of
the dynamic system when this is unknown things
become quite difficult so there are some formal
checks when we try to impose a model structure
we should first check if our model is observable
and we should check the detectability somehow of
the system um which means that which is always
easier to do with linear systems but you can
also do with non-linear systems so this is
an important check to try and do formally
when you try to put a model into the loop for
for purely data driven representations another
check that has to be done because oftentimes
we try to extract the purely data driven model
is the parsimony of the representation
that we extract you know so this this
checks are important and should be in place in
order to have a representation that is really
performant otherwise it could be that you have
overfeeding that you have non-convergence and
that you can you have instability and actually
something that is not usable at the end of the day
totally agree some sort of pre-processing of
the data and make it you know quality data it's
um the model the model as well has to be checked
and it has to be something that is in a position
to operate with the inputs that we have in hand
yeah because here we're not you know since our
interest is to view some sort of model into the
representation it also has to be configured in an
appropriate way right right yeah so nothing is
perfectly automatic some some knowledge has to
be injected uh Peter also asked another question
um Are there specific tools you use to establish
this like yes from the side of the model is
more on observability as I mentioned before
is the parsimony of these models but then when
you're talking about the data it is uh indeed
aspects that have to do with the correlations
of the driving inputs um and different you
know different checks that could guarantee the
sufficiency sample of the data for describing
the problem at hand there's also tests that we do
to understand how linear or non-linear problem is
for example through understanding through using
coherence functions or other types of input output
relationship checks or statistical checks and
awesome that Define the nature of the problem
all right thank you Eleni um um is there any
other question please unmute and ask your question
well I mean um I have many questions but
um you know you know respecting the time
um I guess I can email you uh separately yes I
do I do I can show my email there for I think I
may have it on one of our last slides so this is
an image of our group it also contains my email
where you can reach me with any comments feedback
or also intentions for collaboration that would
be very welcome it's one of the nice outcomes of
stocks so exactly um and I do myself I see that
there are a couple of topics we can collaborate
so I'm very excited that would be awesome I'll
wait to hear from you then from others who may
be interested yeah yeah definitely you will hear
from us for sure all right with that I guess
we can um you know thank our speaker for the
wonderful talk and interesting presentations
and yeah but thank you so much no thank you it
was my pleasure so I hope to get to see you again
soon yeah yeah thank you so much have a nice day